so before the war in Ukraine even began
both Toria Newlin at the state
department the number two of the state
department and Joe Biden threatened to
blow up the nordstream pipeline watch
I want to be clear with you today if
Russia invades Ukraine one way or
another Nordstrom two will not move
forward if Russia invades that means
tanks or troops Crossing the the border
of Ukraine again then there will be we
there will be no longer a Norse team too
we we will bring it into it
would you but how would you how will you
do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's controls
we will uh I promise you we'll be able
to do it
so then the pipelines actually blew up
these pipelines that bring natural gas
from Eastern Europe to Western Europe to
keep the European economy going and they
exploded causing the single largest
human-caused environmental disastery in
all of history and again setting Europe
on the road to actual poverty
so it was an unpopular event and Joe
Biden denied any responsibility in fact
he blamed Russia Joe Biden and his whole
Administration told us that somehow
Russia for reasons they never made clear
just because their evil had sabotaged
their own energy pipeline watch this
it was a deliberate Act of sabotage
and now the Russians are pumping out
disinformation and lies
so that was in September and it was
obvious from the very first day well
that's not true it's not that Vladimir
Putin is too good a person to blow up
Nordstrom but like why would he it only
hurts him and by the way it really hurts
Western Europe but a lot of media
Outlets repeated that lie dutifully
that's what they do and attacked us as
Putin Stooges for having questions about
it well we know a lot more now there
have been a number of official
investigations of what happened and not
one has found any evidence of Russian
involvement and now we have the actual
answer to what happened oh the bite
Administration did it for real
investigative reporter Seymour Hirsch
who's been around for more than 50 years
just wrote a piece on sub stack that
includes this quote last June the Navy
divers U.S Navy divers operating under
the cover of a widely publicized
mid-summer NATO exercise known as ball
tops 22 planted remotely triggered
explosives that three months later
destroyed three of the four Nordstrom
pipelines according to a source with
direct knowledge of the operational
planning now this piece continues it's
probably the most comprehensive news
story you will read this year
Seymour Hersh on substack you should
read it and it recounts in detail
meetings with the National Security
advisor at the White House where this
was planned exactly what explosives were
used how they were triggered by what
aircraft on what day
so many details in here that it is not
possible that it's not true it is true
and in fact no one on a high level in
the US government is denying it with any
specificity and said the White House is
just dismissing this utterly false and
no reporters are following up on this is
that amazing Aaron mate is following up
on it he's with the gray Zone he joins
us tonight
Aaron I I don't remember the last time I
saw a story this well reported it wasn't
in the New York Times Hershey's former
employer they wouldn't have run it but
the fact that nobody at the White House
briefing today even asked about this
story makes me think we are becoming
North Korea
Tucker this is a case where you have the
motive uh the U.S has long been trying
to stop the Nordstrom too because as
Cyrus's story points out the US has
recognized that if Nordstrom 2 goes
online that would make it a lot more
difficult for the U.S to wage a proxy
war against Russia because Germany will
not want to be on board with cutting off
its source of cheap energy so the U.S
found an answer to that problem they
blew it up and it's interesting Hirsch
reports that the planning for this
operation began in late 2021 and that's
when Russian forces were messing on the
border of Ukraine and there was a threat
of the invasion but something else
happened Russia in that same month of
December 2021 when planning was underway
at the White House to blow up Nordstrom
too Russia also submitted draft treaties
to the U.S and NATO laying out detailed
proposals for the U.S NATO to resolve
their issues to roll back NATO military
infrastructure in States surrounding
Russia now we know what happened to that
because the U.S rejected it wouldn't
even discuss the core issue of Ukraine
not joining NATO instead the U.S chose
to basically let the Russian invasion
happen and then when that happened
proceeded to engage in this operation to
blow up Nordstrom too and they've made
no secret about their Embrace of this uh
the day after the Nordstrom 2 was
sabotaged Anthony blinken declared that
this was a tremendous strategic
opportunity and most recently you've
covered this Victoria Newlin testified
in Congress that she is grateful along
with the White House that the Nordstrom
2 is now a Hulk of metal at the bottom
of the sea I mean NATO is a coalition of
European powers led by the United States
the United States just wrecked their
economies I don't see how NATO stays
together after this I I don't but I mean
what do I know um air matte I hope
you'll come back thank you subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight